I'd like you to imagine just for a
moment that your eyelashes grew inwards
instead of outwards so that every time
you blinked they would scrape the front
of your eyeballs damaging the corneas
and so that slowly and painfully you
went blind well that's what happens for
a person who has trachoma now this
little boy here pomelo
from Zambia he has trachoma and if we
don't do anything he's going to go blind
trachoma is a curious disease it's a
bacterial infection that's passed from
person to person and by flies the
repeated infection will scar your
eyelids so that they contract and they
turn inside out particularly affects
women because they have the contact with
children so what you'll often see in
places like Ethiopia are girls who have
tweezers like this around their necks
and they use them to park out their
eyelashes but of course that only gives
them temporary respite because they just
gray back more vicious than before there
are around 2 million people in the world
who are blind or visually impaired
because of trachoma and we believe there
may be as many as 200 million people who
are at risk now it's a very old disease
what you can see here is a photo of a
wall of a tomb in northern Sudan
colleague and I were traveling in a very
remote village and we asked an old man
to take us down into a little - now on
the wall we saw two eyes one is crying
and you can see there are tweezers next
to it Simon said to me my god do you
think that's trachoma so we sent this
picture to the British Museum and they
confirm that yes
trachoma so thousands of years ago the
ancient Nubians were painting pictures
of trachoma on the walls of their tomb
and the tragedy is that disease is still
rampant in that area today and the crazy
thing is we know how to stop it
and what's great is that the trachoma
community have all come together to pool
their efforts we don't compete we
collaborate I have to tell you that's
not always the case in my experience in
the NGO world we've created something
called the International Coalition for
trachoma control and together we've
developed a strategy to fight it this
strategy is called the safe strategy and
it's been approved by the World Health
Organization the S stands for surgery
it's very straightforward procedure to
turn the eyelids back the right way we
trained nurses to do it and they use
local anesthetics and as you can see you
can do it in somebody's front porch if
need be
then a stands for antibiotics these are
donated by Pfizer who also pay for those
drugs to be transported to the port in
country from there they're taken to the
villages where hundreds of thousands of
community volunteers would distribute
those drugs to the people now we train
those volunteers and we also help the
ministries with all that complex
logistics and every one of those
volunteers has a pole like this is
called a dose Pole this one's from
Cameroon and you can see it's marked
different colors and you can tell how
many pills you should give somebody
based on how tall they are f stands for
face washing now we used to have
trachoma in the UK and in the u.s. in
fact President Carter he talks about how
trachoma was a real problem in Georgia
when he was a little boy and in the UK
the famous eye hospital Moorfields was
originally a trachoma Hospital what we
do is teach kids like this how important
it is to wash their faces and finally EE
stands for environment where we help the
communities build latrines and we teach
them to separate their animals from
their living quarters in order to reduce
the fly population so we know how to
tackle the disease but we need to know
where it is and we do because a few
years ago sight savers led an incredible
program called the Global trachoma
mapping project it took us three years
but we went through 29 countries and we
taught local health workers to go
district by district and they examine
the eyelids of over two and a half
million people and they use Android
phones in order to download the data and
from that we were able to build a map
that showed us where the disease was now
this is a very high-level map that shows
you which countries had a problem with
trachoma and you may ask me well you
know does this strategy actually work
and yes it does this map shows you the
progress that we've made to date the
green countries believe they've already
eliminated trachoma and they have either
been through or in the process of having
that validated by the w-h-o countries in
yellow have the money they need they
have the resources to eliminate trachoma
and some of them are really nearly there
but the red countries they don't have
enough funding they cannot eliminate
trachoma unless they get more and we're
quite concerned that the progress to
date may stall so when we were talking
to the audacious ideas guys we asked
ourselves if we really really pushed
ourselves over the next four or five
years and we had the money what do we
think we could achieve well
we believe that we can eliminate
trachoma in 12 African countries and
across the Americas and all across the
Pacific and we can make significant
progress in two countries which have the
highest burden of the disease which is
Ethiopia and Nigeria and in doing all of
that we can leverage more than two
billion dollars worth of donated drugs
now this map here shows you the impact
that we'll have look how many countries
are going green and there you can see
progress in Ethiopia Nigeria now yes
there are some countries that are still
red these are mainly countries which are
in conflict places like Yemen South
Sudan where it's very difficult to work
so we have the team the strategy and the
map and we also have the relationships
with the governments so that we can make
sure that our program is coordinated
with other disease control programs so
that we can be efficient wouldn't it be
amazing if we could do this we'd have
trachoma on the run we would be on the
home straight to eliminate this disease
from the whole world but before I finish
I just want to share with you some words
from the founder of sight savers a guy
called Sir John Wilson now he was
blinded at the age of 12 and he said
people don't go blind by the million
they go blind one by one and in the
excitement of being able to say we've
got rid of trachoma for the whole
country let's not forget that actually
this is a devastating disease that
destroys lives of individual people
people like Treiber now I met why the
last year in Tanzania she had had
trachoma for as long as she could
remember and a couple of months before I
met her she'd had the operation there's
no exaggeration to say that this had
totally transformed her life we'd saved
the site that she had left and she was
free of pain she could sleep she could
work she could socialize and she said to
me I have my life back
and it was impossible not to be moved by
her story but there are so many
treiber's I want to find all the
treiber's and I don't want anyone to go
blind in agony anymore now you know
there are so many intractable problems
in this world but this is not one of
them this is something that we can Souls
and we can ensure that kids like this
can grow up free from the fear of
trachoma so for the sake of kids like
this and for the sake of people like
Treiber
let's get rid of trachoma because you
know cat do you think we can we are if
we really really want to yes we can so
thank you
[Applause]